GETTING STARTED AND I HAVE GOOSE
BUMPS TO GET STARTED FOR
TONIGHT'S GAME AND THIS SEASON.
>> ADAM, LOOK, THIS LEAGUE IS AT
96% VACCINATION RATE AMONG THE
PLAYERS, BUT THERE IS SO MUCH
TALK ABOUT ONE OF THE GUYS WHO
HAS NOT DONE IT, KYRIE IRVING,
AND NOW YOU SAID, LOOK, THIS IS
NOT AN NBA AGAINST KYRIE OR
VERSUS KYRIE, AND YOU THINK THAT
THIS IS NEW YORK CITY LAW OR
REGULATION, AND HOW IT PERTAINS
TO KYRIE.
YET, IT IS AN ISSUE THAT IMPACT
S THE ISSUE ON THE FLOOR, AND IF
YOU COULD SIT DOWN WITH HIM,
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL HIM?
>> I WOULD TELL HIM TO GET
VACCINATED FIRST AND FOREMOST
FOR HIMSELF AND HIS FAMILY AND
THE TEAMMATES AND THE LEAGUE AND
THE COMMUNITY THAT HE CARES SO
MUCH ABOUT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS NOT JUST
KYRIE, AND THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY WHO DISAGREE WITH
THE NOTION OF GETTING
VACCINATED, BUT AT LEAST FROM
EVERYTHING THAT I UNDERSTAND,
SCIENCE IS FIRMLY ON THE SIDE OF
GETTING VACCINATED.
THIS IS IN ESSENCE A MIRACLE
VACCINE, AND THINK OF WHERE WE
WERE WHEN WE STOPPED THE SEASON,
AND THEN WE WENT INTO THE
BUBBLE, AND THEN LAST SEASON AND
THIS VACCINE CAME ALONG AND
ALREADY SAVED TENS OF MILLIONS
OF LIVES.
I THINK AT SOME POINT FOR KYRIE
TO BE ENGAGED MEMBER OF SOCIETY,
AND PUTTING ASIDE THIS LEAGUE,
AND HE NEEDS TO GET VACCINATED,
AND THAT IS THE LAW IN NEW YORK,
AND THE LAW IN NEW YORK IS IF
YOU WANT TO PLAY IN AN ARENA OR
VISIT IN AN ARENA OR PARTICIPATE
IN AN ARENA, YOU HAVE TO BE
VACCINATED AND THAT IS WHERE HE
FINDS HIMSELF AND WHERE WE ARE
AS A LEAGUE.
HERE I AM